自分の代わりをしてくれる人をどう育て
られるかだと思うね。働く人が自分の成長
と会社の発展が1つになる仕組みを作った
ことが今会社がどんどん伸びてる
理由じゃないかと思うんですよ。1億で
終わしって多分ビジョンがないんだと思う
んだよ。青木サの人生額100回聞いたら
豊かになる話。ま、年少1
億円の超え方ということで、ま、大体今日本の国内ですと、ま、年少
1億円未満が大体80%
超えていまして、大体ですね、約19%
の企業しか、ま、年少1
億円超えてないっていう風に言われてるんですけれども、なんかどうしたら年少
億を、ま、超えていく企業体を作っていくことができるのかというテーマについて少し教えていただけますでしょうか?
うん。
ま、それ業種業体によっても違うんじゃ
ないの?単価かける数量かける利益率。
非常にシンプルな方程式だけど、ま、
例えばやさんがね、毎日売っているもの
やっぱりこう何百円とか単価が低いもので
あるなら
ばやっぱり1ヶ月の月勝約900万ぐらい
の売上っていうことは1日いくらかって
こう逆算をした時に1日30万の売上を
これでも休みの日もあるわけだからそ
40万ぐぐらい毎日売
るってやさんってそんな簡単じゃないと
思うんですよ。もう生活に密着したお仕事
ってそう簡単には売上伸ばせないと思う。
じゃあどうするかって言うと
インターネットで例えば3地直走しますよ
とかそういうそのロジスティックス物流の
ねところをちょっとどっかと携しながら
売るということも1つだよね。ま、私の
友人でカの加藤ってね、加藤水産の加藤
さん
は月勝だよ。1ヶ月カを1億ってる経験を
持ってる人なんですよ。これはすごいと
思うのよ。それはまさにインターネットで
カニをそれだけ売ってるわけよ。お父さん
が元々カの量をやってて、で、自分は建築
屋だったんだけど、お父さんの後ついで
インターネットショッピングでカを売って
いる。同じカを売るんでも例えば函館の
朝市に1杯いくらっていう風にそこの店舗
だけでカを売るっていう方法もあるだろう
しやっぱり築地だとかね、いろんなそう
いう市場に下ろすっていう方法もいろんな
ことあるけど、ま、今言ってるように、ま
、その必要性というかね、やっぱりその
マーケットに対して需要と供給でどうやっ
てやっていくのかってことなんで、その
仕事によってやっぱり変化があるよね。
ただ、ま、大きくすればいいってわけでは
ないけれども、鍵はね、やっぱり人の育成
だと思います。自分の代わりをしてくれる
人をどう育てられるかだと思うのよ。人の
会社っていうか、よその業種業体っていう
のはまたその専門の人たちがいらっしゃる
と思うけれども、ま、実際うちで学んでる
8000人以上の経営者の方々を見ても
1億の壁を超えてる経営者の共通は採用と
育成とその他店舗展開をした時の幹部育成
ができる。そういう1つの技術があるよね
。だからやっぱり採用と育成、さらに営業
マーケティング、財務戦略やっぱり店舗
出していくってことなると投資も必要に
なってくるし、それからやっぱりこう差別
化された戦略的なやっぱり事業計画を
しっかり立てながら投資を何年で回収して
いくのかっていう新規事業の展開やあとは
根っこからだんだんミきを枝をこう太くし
ていきながらトータルで壁をこう破って
いく。135の壁だよね。アチンメントも
最初は年少1億目指したんですよ。38年
前で1億の壁を破り、次は3億の壁を破り
、5億の壁を破りで10億の壁を破るのに
20年買ってる。ちょうど創業から20年
の時に売上10億、経利益2億。これを
社員50人で達成したわけだ。だ、
パーヘッド2000万ですよね。で、その
時に初めて私は企業家のための社長額とか
小さな会社で大きく設ける方とかうし組み
の作り方とか戦略を超える理念経営という
経営に関する本を初めて書いた。だから
経営者教育に入るの20年かかったんです
よ。それまでは営業教育のアチューメント
だったの。結局自分の等身台であとは個人
事業者の人とか今は当費数的にこう発展し
てってるわけだよね。今期は72億ぐらい
の売上。経常利益は今の状態だと22億
ぐらいに着地すると思うんですよね。も
そうやって考えたらね、最初1億円の売上
を目指した会社が今経で20億の会社に
なってるわけですよね。去年も20億
以上行ってる。昨年は18億と。だから
急激に良くなってってる。じゃあなぜ
かって言うと、
2005年から新卒が入ってきて、新卒
採用に直接投資したお金は4億7000万
なんですよ。ま、うちの業種の場合は、え
、コンサル業界、トレーナーを育てて
るっていう意味では、やっぱり現場型の
人材を育てながら1人1人の
パフォーマンスを最大にできるように、ま
、半期年性の仕組みを作り、年の決算商用
で税引ご利益の3割を社員に分配をする。
ま、3割は内部流法、3割は配当、1割は
社会還元とこの仕組みを作ってどうなん
だろう?働く人が自分のマインド、
ノーハウスキル、成長と会社の発展が1つ
になる仕組みを作ったことが今会社が
どんどん伸びてる理由じゃないかと思うん
ですよ。だから1億で終わってしまう人
って多分ビジョンがないんだと思うんだよ
。やっぱり目指してくことで全ての器が
拡張するんじゃないかな。なんかさ、今
だけ金だけ自分だけみたいなちっぽけな
考え持っていたり、それから自分のこう
職人としてのま、例えば腕で食べていけれ
ばいいやで。もし考えたらそれ以上はいか
ないと思う。大きく考えていく。それはま
、心志しなんじゃないかな。夢って言って
もいいけど、夢って言うと利己的なものに
なるので、やっぱり僕は心志しの方が組織
力になると思ってますね。だから1億の壁
を破るにはアグローリッチだと思うよ。
いや、実際そうだと思うわ。考え方を
大きくしない限り器が大きくならないと
その入れ物以上の水って入らないじゃん。
やっぱりシンクビッグなんじゃないの?
1億円でいいやってなったらで終わりだよ
。だから所得で満足するのか売上で満足
するのかどっかで満足するんだよ。僕は
全然満足してませんよ。感謝はしてるけど
。ていうのはもっと社員を豊かにしたいの
。俺集3日を目指してんだからで平均収入
800万目指してんのよ。それをいつの
時点で実現するのかって今チャレンジし
てるわけよ。ほら、こうやってチャレンジ
していくと仕事って面白いもの
で社員がそう工夫してくんですよ
[音楽]
。もう一言で言えばビッグ。もうそれしか
ない。だから1億をまず目指して達成し
たら3億。次は5億と。でもそれはね、
仕事に携わる人が確信を持てる商品を与え
られないといけないので、技術であろうと
商品であろうと、ここの差別化区分か専門
家、これ大事ですよ。だから商品力で差別
化するか、営業力で差別化するか、いずれ
にしても何か強みを徹底的に磨かなきゃ
いけない。うん。あとは採用と育成ですね
。それがやっぱり大きく成長するための
秘訣なんじゃないでしょうか。ま、経営者
は人生理念作りから始めなさいっていう私
の著所もあるので、ま、読んでいただける
と参考にしていただけると思いますし、
拒否を築づく思考法。これ私がすごい力
入れてるのでナポレオンヒルの著作物の
代表的なものですからこのシンク&
グローリッチを読んでもらうとビッグに
なれると思いますので是非頑張って
ください。よろしくお願いします。え、
是非ね、え、チャンネル登録いいなと思っ
たらよろしくお願いします。これからもね
、是非応援してください。え、また次回の
YouTubeでおめに帰りましょう。
ありがとうございます。
[音楽]
ちなみにその青木社長が創業当時に、ま、最初
1億、3億、5
億ってこう目指していたっておっしゃられてたんですけれども、売上、ま、
1億、年少1
億を目指してなんか取り組まれたこととか何かあられるんですか?
あ、単純な話。それば採用と育成だよ。もうそれずっとやってるよ。
あのね、営業にさる人間
が確信を持てる商品を与えられ、やる気の
出る環境で仕事をすることができ、やる気
のある人材を次々と採用することができ、
採用した人間を1人前に育てる仕組みを作
るってことなんです。これが
営業型のいわゆる経営。ま、経営っていう
のは物を作って売って管理するわけだから
。だそういう意味ではなんだろうな。私は
どっちかて言うとね、そのセールスマン
上がりの経営者ですから、やっぱり1
セールスマンの時にトップを目指し、
マネージャーになってトップを目指し、
コンサルタになってトップ目指して、で、
結果29歳の時にコンサル会社に移って、
そこで3年で売上7倍にして、で、独立し
たわけでしょ。32歳でずっと変わらない
んだよね。だ実は僕は若い時から今も同じ
ことをずっと言い続けてるよう感じ。いや
、本当にだけどどうなんだろう。営業
にさる人間は確信を持てる商品を与えられ
てけど時代の流れに即して本当に良いもの
を提供しようということは終わりがないよ
ね。そうでしょ。で、やる気の出る環境で
仕事をすることができ、これはフェアで
あることや自己実現の舞台を与えてあげ
たいと。だから
グレイトプレスワークでグランプリも取れ
ましたよね。うん。だけどそれを目指した
わけじゃないんだよね。僕はもう社員
可愛いんですよ。うん。なんだろう。本当
に本気で社員を幸せにしたいと思ってる。
これはもう本音ですね。うん。認めてあげ
たいし、もっと豊かにしてあげたいし、
ただね、まあなんだろう、僕にも課題が
あるんですよ。それは今は私がある意味で
知恵があり、その付加価値の高い商品を
作り上げそれがその社員の質も良くてお客
様に対してそういう1億を3億にしようと
か、ま、1億3億、5億を目指すね。そう
いう、ま、中小企業の経営者もたくさん
うち来てくれてるので、まだ私が38年
取り組んできたことは実なので、それは
非常に参考にしていただけるものだと思う
んだけど、この後だよね。今この
YouTube見ていただいてね、
こな間だも8名ぐらい新規の人来てくれて
たって。そうしたらね、考えてみるとまあ
なんだろう。これ1つのなんて言うの?
管理者を1人雇ったと同じぐらいの効果が
あるわけじゃないですか?ある意味ではね
。だから、ま、毎月うちは何箇所でもやる
わけだからね、この講座を。うん。年間僕
の特別講座も今2000名みんな受行を
目指してね、来てくれてる。あとは
ナポレオンヒル財団に認定をいいた、え、
アチュメントマスタープログラムね。この
アチメントテクノロジーのマスター
プログラムのファシリテーターを育ててい
くっていうようなこと。こういうのも僕は
ムアの原点で色々考えていってやっぱり
ナポレオヒルの成功理論をな何て言うん
だろう?縦糸横糸で選択と成功哲学を
きちっとその折り物のように合わせて
新しい時代の求めるアチュメント
テクノロジーというね、つまり人間関係を
犠牲にしないで、高いパフォーマンスを
乱出す技術を研究してるわけじゃん。だ、
こういうことをサンドの飯より好きだって
いう人間が次の台に入れば大丈夫です。だ
、それはね、大きな僕はテーマ、これから
の課題ですよね。うん。だからむは言うの
原点なんです。1番大事なの
は考えよう。うん。できない英語を力づく
言いました。
決して負けない経営なんです。まず経営者
自身がお金よりも仕事の内容をそのものに
惚れ込んでるかどうかです。